Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to get a taste of how insanely
quick progress is in machine learning research.
In March of 2020, a paper appeared that goes
by the name Neural Radiance Fields, NERF in
short.
With this technique, we could take a bunch
of input photos, get a neural network to learn
them, and then, synthesize new, previously
unseen views of not just the materials in
the scene, but the entire scene itself.
And here, we are talking not only digital
environments, but also, real scenes as well!
Just to make sure, once again, it can learn
and reproduce entire real-world scenes from
only a few views by using neural networks.
However, of course, NERF had its limitations.
For instance, in many cases, it had trouble
with scenes with variable lighting conditions
and lots of occluders.
And to my delight, only 5 months later, in
August of 2020, a followup paper appeared
by the name NERF in the Wild, or NERF-W in
short.
Its speciality was tourist attractions that
a lot of people take photos of, and we then
have a collection of photos taken during a
different time of the day, and of course,
with a lot of people around.
And, lots of people, of course means, lots
of occlusions.
NERF-W improved the original algorithm to
excel more in cases like this.
And we are still not done yet, because get
this, only three months later, on 2020 November
25th, another followup paper appeared by the
name Deformable Neural Radiance Fields.
D-NERF.
The goal here is to take a selfie video, and
turn it into a portrait that we can rotate
around freely.
This is something that the authors call a
nerfie.
If we take the original NERF technique to
perform this, we see that it does not do well
at all with moving things.
And here is where the deformable part of the
name comes into play.
And now, hold on to your papers and marvel
at the results of the new D-NERF technique.
A clean reconstruction.
We indeed get a nice portrait that we can
rotate around freely and all of the previous
NERF artifacts are gone.
It performs well even on difficult cases with
beards, all kinds of hairstyles, and more.
And now, hold on to your papers, because glasses
work too, and not only that, but it even computes
the proper reflection and refraction off of
the lens.
And this is just the start of a deluge of
new features.
For instance, we can even zoom out and capture
the whole body of the test subject.
Furthermore, it is not limited to people,
it also works on dogs too, although in this
case, we will have to settle with a lower
the resolution output.
It can pull off the iconic dolly zoom effect
really well.
And, amusingly, we can even perform a nerfception,
which is recording ourselves as we record
ourselves.
I hope that now you have a good feel of the
pace of progress in machine learning research,
which is absolutely incredible.
So much progress in just 9 months of research.
My goodness.
What a time to be alive!
Thanks
for watching and for your generous support,
and I'll see you next time!